welcome to CBS this morning we will
begin with this Democrats on Capitol
Hill want to hear from top immigration
officials about an explosive new report
that claims conditions at Border Patrol
facilities are so bad that one manager
called them a ticking time bomb new
photo shows severe overcrowding the
Homeland Security department's Inspector
General says at one facility some adults
were held in standing-room-only
conditions for a week that follows a
recent visit where Democrats toured
facilities in Texas and claimed to have
seen horrifying conditions Mireya
Villarreal
is in McAllen Texas outside a Border
Patrol facility spotlighted in the
report Mireya what are we learning well
you know here's what we know at this
point inspectors visited five Border
Patrol facilities along the southern
border including the one that you see
behind me that is one of the busiest in
the country they are concerned with
overcrowding and they say prolonged
detention is creating this immediate
risk to both the health and the safety
of the migrants and also the agents
inside across the country Tuesday
hundreds of people turned out for
protests demanding migrant detention
centers be closed we are collectively
astounded and horrified
the cruelty that is going on in our
border the Office of Inspector General
released these photos Tuesday allegedly
showing dangerous overcrowding at
several border patrol facilities this
one from early June apparently shows 71
men being held in a cell with a capacity
for 41 women at Border Patrol's Fort
Brown station in Texas in its new report
the office says overcrowding is so bad
desperate detainees at one facility went
so far as to clogging toilets with mylar
blankets and socks in order to be
released from their cells during
maintenance investigators also say they
observed overcrowding at facilities
where children are being held and that
many are being held longer than legally
allowed at three facilities they visited
investigators say children had no access
to showers
and at two facilities no access to hot
meals this video of a 12 year old
migrant girl speaking to her immigration
attorney about the alleged conditions of
the Border Patrol facility in Clinton
Texas is where she was held for 12 days
they gave us little food some children
did not bathe the girl said in Spanish
they were mean to us the Department of
Homeland Security did not comment for
this report but they did acknowledge the
findings in the report and say that
what's happening here at the southern
border is an acute and worsening crisis
the House Oversight Committee has called
an emergency hearing and they are asking
the heads of both DHS and CBP to come
testify next week tony garea thank you